leute ich bin richtig stolz auf uns
haben quasi jetzt sechs sauber stehen
wir kein einziges machen und gucken was
sie machen
er heilt uns glaube ich wenn wir ihnen
wie links haben der macht zusammen
windstoß der macht feuer der vergiftet
jemanden das ist ein flugzeug starb und
er macht als alter geil wir sind so gut
aufgestellt
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
neuen folge minecraft kilo auf dem heck
sitzt minecraft heck sind auf dem rost
über mein gott ist immer wieder falsch
wie ihr wahrscheinlich schon sehe habe
ich ein wenig wasser meiner fans kaum
verändert also nur ganz klein bisschen
die ist jetzt anders und zwar ist die
ein bisschen mehr angesagt an mich aber
irgendwie so dass forderten ja ein paar
leute jetzt nicht erwiderte am hellsten
und was auch einige meinten was ich
machen könnte sei moment ich kann
irgendwie ob diese schadens tafel in die
mitte ziehen ich wusste mal wie das geht
ich habe es allerdings wieder vergessen
ist jetzt auch egal jetzt liegt also
diese schadensart für die jetzt oben
links ist wenn ich irgendein tier
angucke aber das jetzt erst mal relativ
egal jedenfalls was ich sagen wollte ist
ich hab' folge 43 schon mal auf wissen
hier passiert halter deswegen schrieb
einer luft gesprengt also wegen mir war
das nicht
ich darf doch nicht drangehen ich darf
mir keine blöcke bei anderen
das ist das alter wäre anders wenn mir
ist hart was schiefgelaufen cas gemacht
denn da ist was schief gelaufen
hast du das selbst ja gut okay und zwar
erst mal ganz kurz zusammen ich mach
jetzt mal wieder rein
die folge ist mir verloren gegangen und
zwar passiert das einmal in 500 aufnahme
versuchen dass die kommt das ist raps
einfach meint videodatei ist beschädigt
du kannst sie mit keinem programm öffne
ich hab's mit vlc quicktime mediaplayer
itunes premiere und after effects
probiert ich konnte nirgendwo mit öffnen
das war eigentlich nicht sehr geile
folge also ich hab meinen chocobo
zurückgeholt aus dem messer wollte man
chocobo dann da also da oben ist es
wollten einem schoko das war minim
nenner gefangen und zwar wo das doch
nicht von dem getötet sondern die zweite
mein zweites mut von tim getötet das
erste mal im netz
danke dass ihr mir das so fleißig wie
kommt da geschrieben habt also hier ist
mein job jetzt wieder dem wollte ich
hier oben noch zum dach bauen oder hier
sondern
etwas größeren stall das hatte ich halt
überlegt und hier oben dann irgendwie
noch etwas anderes drauf zumal sein
wasser voller keine ahnung ist dann hab
ich mir die scale brüstung komplett
gemacht einfach guckt mal hier ich habe
eine komplette scale richtung und die
habe ich sogar schon verzaubert weil ich
lange der monster falle drin war und ich
hab da mal ein schwert und verloren das
hat man in folge 42 gesehen allerdings
habe ich dann wieder bekommen weil ich
mit dieser sky mit dieser diamond life
die mega mega geil ist wenn das sharp
mit 2 drauf ist dies richtig richtig
stark wenn amok sind oder so
sie kann einfach mal so 30 mops auf
einmal töten wie auf einem haufen stehen
das ist mega gut
deswegen denke ich dass ich dir jetzt
immer mal so reparieren werde wohl das
kann ich nicht das muss ich glaube ich
daran machen
damit habe ich dann halt mein schwert
wieder bekommen so was als trieb er
drücke geil so ein bisschen na gut und
ja dann habe ich außerdem ein elektriker
verzaubert alle möglichen sachen da
drauf hat wie an breaking und sowas und
da haben wir auch an viele leute in die
kommentare geschrieben dass ich damit
nichts bringen soll also nicht so
sondern lieber so so immer mal so ein
bisschen drücken dankeschön an euch an
die ganzen tipps damals noch einige dass
man den nicht reparieren kann einige
meinten allerdings dass ich den hier
drin irgendwie reparieren kann
ob das funktioniert weiß nicht jetzt
gerade funktioniert nicht aber ich habe
auch keine level dann müsste ich dann
irgendwie töten gleich und was ich auch
gemacht habe ist meine gagliano ein
bisschen verzaubert ich hab's aber auf
jeden drauf damit ich direkt nach dem
tod noch habe protection wollte jetzt
auch noch packen dann wollte ich noch
ein bisschen zum monster falle gehen
damit ich da so einen becher erfahrungen
sammeln kann hat allerdings nicht so
ganz geklappt
ich wollte eigentlich gerade aufnehmen
mit hedos oder mit komme aber
die sind halt beide im moment verhindert
weil also die vorliebe einzigen wenn die
gal online waren und na ja das war's
eigentlich was in der letzten folge
gemacht habe vielmehr habe ich
eigentlich gar nicht gemacht habe ich
eigentlich noch in meinem rucksack ups
irgendwas daran dass nichts drin und
sonst wollte ich eigentlich dann auch
mal wieder irgendeinen in festungen
gehen und dann irgendwie ein paar
essenzen heraushandeln
und noch ein paar zauberstäbe machen
mittlerweile allgemein mal gucken was es
noch so für zauberstäbe gibt und ihr
habt mir ich habe ja jemand seine
achtung dieser healing ist darf der es
mit leid ist es okay ich wollte ein paar
zauberstäbe halt machen und diesen job
allerdings machen
du hast tribut gezahlt aber bttv haben
es geklaut es ist deine pflicht ist
getan und du musst nichts mehr tun danke
du hast tribut gezahlt aber appetit
ja das war auch so eine sache und zwar
stand bei mir letzte folge ein schild
von caps so total börse so just lizenzen
du hast electric essenzen von mir
geklaut dass meine warte wo habe ich die
denn da sind die denn da meinte cap das
sind meine und ich sehe ich habe gar
keine von dir genommen
aber die haben belegen die brocken
zusammengeklaut haben wie gesagt dass
ich das war oder keine ahnung warum
kämpft mich verdächtigt hatte ich weiß
es nicht
naja live ist
ich werde jetzt mal ganz viel electric
stark machen diamond und stick die am
anblick den man doch wo sind meine
jemanden wirklich rasch mehr mm stecker
kabel stecker okay gut so ich glaube
viel mehr kann ich damit ja auch gar
nicht machen mit diesem magic essenzen
und dann werde ich mir jetzt erstmal
hier noch seinen lieblings darf machen
ich werde mir erst mal alles machen was
ist eigentlich gibt mit den ganzen stoff
sachen ja den habe ich schon das gibt es
noch so für essenzen lotte tänzerischen
poison viel wind und elektrik darf mache
ich mir auch erst mal und zwar mache ich
das hier so jetzt hab ich einen winzer
zwischen troisdorf so und ein zauberstab
electric zauberstab und das war es ja
freunde ich würde sagen wir sind
mittlerweile eigentlich sehr sehr gut
aufgestellt würde ich jetzt mal so grob
behaupten
ich weiß andere haben das auch schon
aber ich würde
ich weiß halt dass viele andere dass
immer alles so geschenkt bekommen haben
deswegen ich bin eigentlich sehr sehr
stolz auf uns dass wir die ganzen sachen
so und selbst alles beigebracht haben
ich mit euch zusammen es werden
natürlich wieder viele wagen andere ja
auch aber ich bin irgendwie da stolz auf
unser wir testen jetzt mal die ganzen
zauber stimme so moment leute wir haben
jetzt hier quasi das komplette inventar
voller zauberstäbe werden jeden
einzelnen zauberstab den es gibt glaube
ich mal da waren wir alle text of
darkness sensor an den kenn ich nicht
sollte moustafa
was macht der konsums tortoise template
wärmen langdistanz bord kostet extra
acht äckern deutsches machen kloster und
das brauchen wir dafür place magma und
gold eigentlich ein netter leute ich bin
richtig stolz von sie haben quasi jetzt
sechs sauber stehen wir keinen platz
gutmachen und gucken was die machen der
heilt uns glaube ich wenn wir irgendwie
links haben der macht so ein windstoß
der macht feuerwehr vergiftet jemanden
das ist ein flugzeug starb und er macht
als alter geil wir sind so gut
aufgestellt mittlerweile hat macht oder
wie soll ich mir das vorstelle mit dem
eis
ich kann jetzt einfach mal einen schoko
protest werden ja genug und dann würde
ich sagen setzen uns auch mal langsam ab
das ist ein blöder viele triebe lama
nicht mehr hab ich kacke
ich kann ja nicht mehr so hoch springen
ich brauche dann irgendwie ich glaube
ich muss dann immer noch so ein paar
schuhe mitbringen mit denen er ich
springen kann
so versetzt gemacht die sind jetzt alle
stehen geblieben
das kann ich am kampf richtig gut nur
weil ich einmal im moment da wird er
verstehen oder mach ich mag er stirbt
nein nein bleibt stehen bleibt die
mächtigkeiten und mich hätten bleibt auf
den weg stehen würde ich sowieso nicht
ich kann nicht nein
irgend ein gott der wird nicht was
gestorben so vince darf kann ich damit
einfach so wegdrücken york an immer
wegdrücken
ach ich hab in giacomo getötet oh mein
gott oh entschuldigung tut mir leid
ihr könnt ihn auf essen leiter das volk
animalisch ich sollte mich gefreut auf
essen wo mein gott das tut mir leid
gesichtsfeldes einigungsstelle möchte
auch mal ein goldenes ja keine ahnung
ich bin ich froh dass wir jetzt die
ganzen sachen hier haben und dann können
uns ja langsam auch mal um die
essensausgabe kümmern und zwar werde ich
dann jetzt die zauberstäbe der verein
packen nur das was ich brauche zum
beispiel links darf electrics darf und
vielleicht auch noch als nämlich dann
mit polster freuen ich weiß da freu mich
wenn es da freue ich den laptop kann ich
jetzt mal verlieh machen
lieber erst mal so hier so dann kommen
wir noch ein paar unnötige sachen rein
so ja wir sortieren weil das macht man
irgendwann einem livestream wenn ich
denn mal irgendwie dazu kommen werde
dass die qualität besser wird in den
livestreams irgendwann auch sehr viele
leute dass die helligkeit in meiner face
cam mega über hält ist findet ihr das
über hält etwas findet ihr dass ich so
an meinem bild hier ändern könnte wenn
ich so hier so düsseldorf erreicht ich
hole mir auch zu weihnachten
wahrscheinlich einen kompressor und
equalizer also noch mehr in die richtung
bessere audioqualität was wünscht ihr
euch eigentlich zu weihnachten schreibt
es in die kommentare
das wird mich auf jeden fall mega mit
media metrix profitieren die auch zu
weihnachten wünscht naja einige meinten
dass man bezüglich des electric darf ich
hab sie launig sollst du hast du das ist
jetzt auch mein schwert bezogen und zwar
das falsch angeblich verzaubert und zwar
bis stieler drauf und nicht so viel da
seht ihr so stieler und das ist
eigentlich was anderes als stil wenn ich
das schwert reparieren will soll ich
wählen mit der skype bekommen und die in
einen essenz keeper packen also skype
das ist diese waffe die ich vorhin mal
benutzer wie man so gedrückt halten muss
wie sonnen bogen und hier soll ich
erstmal stieler runter packen und das
stil drauf packen weil das angeblich was
anderes ressort steel us steel 14 broich
dafür ua und das kern wohl nicht so
miteinander das kommt nicht klar also
wenn nicht sie als nicht kompatibel mit
stil das heißt ich soll so stieler ist
runter packen hab ich jetzt gemacht aber
ich brauche jetzt ein level und deswegen
werde ich dann wahrscheinlich gleich
wenn wieder tag ist in
turm noch eben da ganz hinten rein gehen
und da dann versuchen so ein bisschen
opfer täten mir wohl auch geschrieben
mit schauspieler kann man seelen sol
chart von also das ist halt das wenn ich
mit einer waffe irgendwem tötet das
werde ich dann wahrscheinlich auf meinen
diamond award mal eben drauf packen
darauf wenn ich jetzt damit mobbte kommt
daraus eine seele und die kann ich in
einem skatepark geschrieben so cage das
ist auch das ist einfach nur eisen für
dann werde ich mir auch so eine kleine
monster falle machen
so ich habe zehn von diesen soll kate
ist dann werde ich wahrscheinlich
irgendwo unterirdisch von mir sondern
sonderlings machen so erwischt bescheid
kann ich dann soll cage packen und dann
habe ich ein sportler mit den gefangenen
seelen allerdings
brauche ich um die seelen zu fangen erst
mal einen cent keeper war das glaube ich
es fesselt ender perlen bräuchte 40
ender perlen in der nähe das nix 123 123
123 ich nicht gedacht dass welche
abbrechen so 123 123 123 so die drei
habe ich jetzt
und sonst müsste da eigentlich bucher
ist sind sie kenne ich gar nicht ja dann
sonst gehe ich jetzt ganz kurz kennen
und dann würde ich sagen wenn man ganz
kurz in den turm da hinten versucht ein
paar leute umzubringen und ich schaue
dann mal
ob das dann wirklich was bringt ob das
alles so klappt wie ich mir das
vorstelle mit meiner monster falle weil
wenn caps jetzt hier kaputt ist
irgendwie dann wäre das ja schon ganz
cool wenn ich daran meine ein bisschen
aufbauen könnte in netter müssen wir
dann auch noch gehen wegen den globus
sachen und so eislaufschuhe muss ich mir
auch noch machen die dänen auch hat so
womit man sowas wasser laufen können
letztendlich die geschenkt bekommen hat
oder ob der sich die selbst gekracht hat
bei denen er statt seiner sache geht es
eigentlich rein gibt es da noch
irgendwas irgendwie mops oder sekt mit
mir ein bisschen wundern ich glaube
nicht als erstmal so rein
hallo entschuldigungen dieser eines
dafür echt geil der so fackeln macht und
so das wäre cool
hallo komme ich überhaupt irgendwie rein
eigentlich müsste ich das schlimmste ein
ich würde gern ein wenig darin verweilen
und doch jetzt nicht drin
ich hoffe mal dass jetzt in welchem ops
kommen aber nicht so viele heftige harte
starke sowie der letztens dann waren das
war nicht für cool so hier sind
mengering basten müssen vielleicht ein
bisschen unnötig das alles zu kräften
wie auch ein bisschen heftig dass sie
noch keiner drin war
doch hier wahrscheinlich höhe
entschuldigung herr logo sind
irgendwelche ops oder soll gegen den
mann umbringen kann
ach ich glaube hier wird auch unser
dings gemacht unsere abstimmung da wo
ich nicht konnte da ist übrigens schön
böse leute habe ein bisschen angst nein
verdammt jetzt hätte ich hier fast mich
selbst im tod gerissen
hier sind ja erst mal kloster und sachen
das heißt so ein bisschen wolle könne
man endlich auch immer mal gebrauchen
reisen mit nämlich nicht mehr egal ich
will jetzt auch nicht stoppen gleich in
vier minuten wenden wenn ich genau hier
drin bin aber das ist geil wenn ich hier
kann ich aus eurer diesem kloster in
sachen kann ich da allerdings raus lacht
das ist eine red storm lampe ach so
stark los dann hallo jungs
leider sind kisten komme ich da
irgendwie so hoch ich höre zombies hallo
da sind welche potash ist ricky hier mit
dem schnee drin denn es hieß dass ohne
kitze ich denke hier waren auch keiner
oder war hier schon jemand immer noch
nicht diamond herren am boden kann ich
mitnehmen für unsere monster dingsbums
das ist hier hinten so drin
das ist nicht gut stephanie hamann
schwert bisschen angst vor denen ich
höre böse sachen oh mein gott nein nein
da mit ua ich habe die ganzen spinnen
runterfallen oder fallen die einfach
über mich irgendwo runter so was war
jetzt noch drin
kulisch golden set play day of hope
longo und leckeres darf das ist gut
ich mach mal ganz kurz meinen rucksack
auf den pakt alle sachen die ich zur
zeit dass man nicht brauche
das bereinigtes bräunig dass bei nicht
dass das das dass das das da hast du
zwischen sloan ist so ich möchte hiermit
eigentlich boxen damit ich hier
dingsbums ich nehme meinen den stab
nämlich auch mal mit und diese tauschen
hier vielleicht kann ich ja damit so ein
bisschen so handeln ihr wisst bescheid
es ist 18 minuten ich versuche jetzt mal
ganz kurz dahinter hinzu kommen möchte
hier auch ein bisschen unterhaltung
liefern
ich nehme mich mal nur so ganz klein
bisschen muss ich mein electric sda
da okay zur not kann ich immer noch
runter springt
erst das tot so kommt als auch welche
ich hoffe man nicht dass meine pfeile
gleich irgendwann ausgehen bisschen
angst vor diesem typen diese mir so ein
bisschen ungeheuer aber sonst auch nix
hier irgendwie ich meine dafür dass sie
mich letzte mal hier so angestellt haben
ist es echt eigentlich relativ pipifax
so ist ihr noch irgendwas mit charts und
bisher gar nichts eigentlich das geht ja
relativ wie sogar letzte mal bin ich
halt direkt rein gegangen dann halt auch
nur mehr schwer das war ein bisschen
doof
sonst würde ich sagen das war's haben
welche electric essenzen bekommen aber
werden die existenz ja mann und zwei
diamanten das ist auch ganz gut
was jetzt so richtig die data center
bringen muss ich da noch rausfinden
aber ich finde wir haben auf jeden fall
schon mal ach jetzt auch noch was ich
nehme ganz kurz mit fackeln und schminke
das schon mal ein bisschen rein hier
ach ja die spitzhacke pro jahr noch
mittel um gespielt und bekam jetzt krieg
will wird so krieg ja weil sonst
ich muss jetzt aber aufhören
ja gut freunde ich halt einfach mal hier
auf
hier sind keine alten drin hier war
schon einer hätte dich gekillt freunde
dann würde ich sagen wenn es euch
gefallen habe ich mich über eine
positive bewertung freuen wir sehen uns
dann beim in der nächsten folge morgen
wieder
und sonst wir sehen uns einfach dann
wieder wenn ihr wieder bock habt jetzt
werde ich erst mal noch den kontakt
schneiden weil er jetzt ja auch noch
heute kommen muss und dann sehen wir uns
im kontakt wieder da müsst ihr müsst
euch auf jeden fall angucken war das ist
ein geiles ein geiles feature der in der
mitte hat wird witzig seiten her egal
haut allein bis zum nächsten mal was gut
und teuer